and then you did a completed like a
couple of mad sketches right me one one
you with you and Ike with mean Ike
Barinholtz I knew like from Chicago yeah
I knew you from here and then you know
what I also remember as we would go to
like Steve and I would go to that
Brazilian with that Brazilian oh my god
in Burbank yeah which one is it that
sure is Korea yeah it's a trois Korea it
called meet what it's called I can't
remember what it's called it's over in
the media center like downtown Burbank
but yeah we went to there and remember
you just do the green light right then
you ate so much do I recall you being
mad at me because I did an interview or
something where I said that I call Eric
Stonestreet to get me like good
restaurants no I would never be met why
would I I think you gave me [ __ ] was at
you or not somebody not me how was it
yeah when did you do an interview Korea
I did like I did like a some sort of
like interview and I said that where do
you get because I remember I talked to
you I said I bought tinder I thought I
said I heard about this we have to Delta
in a sec remember I taught you about
tinder yeah you did and you got offered
in you know I did get off of it yeah
well after a while is the same old same
thing it's like it's like a game but not
I mean meeting people cuz I really meet
people off the dating apps but just
swiping people's pictures it just feels
like I'm playing some sort of game
because it's follow you on it seven
years yeah yeah but did you go on any
dates on it yeah yeah of course but it
was cool for me go for a while yeah yeah
you you definitely got me going on that
yeah cuz I heard that way did you really
yeah I didn't see
I missed my chance we'd be doing this
podcast together big room 70 commercial
more IBM than him
[Music]